you got a car yes is it is it is it  after is it a 2010 or older yeah 2013  your car can be remote controlled  yeah no not my  uh I think anything after 2010 can be  fully remote controlled what and now  they're passing regulations where you  can't go over a certain speed limit in  Europe where they have black boxes where  they listen to everything watch  everything uh and we'll be be able to  take full control of your car in Europe  that's some of the legislation that  they're passing over there essentially  allowing the government to hack and  control every aspect of your Driving  Experience so we're sitting here being  like how dare they go after Elon Musk oh  also he's doing really crazy scary stuff